depuis bientôt trois ans des ingénieurs
et des travailleurs déconstruisent le
vieux pont Champlain il retire ses
pièces une à une c'est vraiment une
déconstruction c'est pas une démolition
donc pour faire un parallèle c'est comme
le jeu de Mikado faut tirer les bons
bâtons dans le bon ordre pour s'assurer
que la structure s'écroule pas
le défi c'est de démanteler 200000
tonnes de béton et 25000 tonnes d'acier
sans contaminer le fleuve Saint-Laurent
entre l'île des sœurs et la Voie
maritime du Saint-Laurent 30 travées
fêtes de béton ont été soulevés d'un
seul tenant
plus tiré en amont du pont
des pelles mécaniques les ont démolis
directement sur l'eau loin des résidents
des débris de béton ont été transportés
jusqu'au quai puis expédié vers un
centre de valorisation pour être
réutilisé dans des chaussées la travée
principale qui surplombait la voie
maritime a été descendu d'un seul bloc
suspendu au bout de 6 câbles c'est une
première au Canada ou ce qu'il va avoir
une descente d'une section aussi
imposante et aussi lourde en un seul
morceau
la structure d'acier a atterri sur une
barge avant d'être remarqué quelques
kilomètres en amont sur la Rive-Sud du
fleuve pour être des mots clés quelques
pièces serviront à des fins de recherche
d'autres seront réutilisés mais la
grande majorité a pris le chemin d'une
fonderie
dans un rayon de 150 km donc ça c'est
une mesure qui évite que la scie soit
mis dans des containers et chipé à
l'étranger pour être recyclé à
l'étranger pour ensuite nous être
revendu
le vieux pont Champlain aura disparu
d'ici le printemps
seuls quelques piles choisies pour
rester debout rappelleront l'existence
de cet ouvrage l'entend iconique dans le
paysage de Montréal ici Dominique Forget
Radio-Canada à Montréal